salut on dit souvent qu'il faut se
concentrer sur une chose pour bien la
faire mais peut-on faire plusieurs
choses en même temps aujourd'hui je vais
vous parler du mode multitâche du
cerveau je vais également mentaliser une
personne ça fait longtemps et vous
donner des conseils pour gérer plusieurs
actions même temps et aujourd'hui il y
aura un bonus et la fin de la vidéo
génériques
[Musique]
il faut pas confondre le fait de faire
plusieurs choses en même temps avec
l'attention même s'il existe certes un
pont entre les deux la concentration sur
un point précis permet justement de
duper le cerveau comme dans la vidéo je
vous avais mis au défi vous pouvez la
voir ici et d'ailleurs vous venez juste
de vivre à l'instant je sais je vous
entends dire dans les commentaires
vous avez cru voir quelque chose bouge
est juste là derrière moi mais c'est
peut-être un simple détournement
d'attention qui vous a empêché de voir
bac j'avais changé de tee-shirt
oui vous pourrez vérifier de base on
sait très bien faire deux choses en même
temps discuté en regardant ces réseaux
sociaux m ait en regardant une vidéo
hein quoi ça c'est vu peut-être ou
encore téléphoner en conduisant
et ça c'est une belle connerie pour
rappel une étude a prouvé de téléphoner
en conduisant augmente le risque
d'accidents mortels par un
multiplicateur de 5
nous savons traiter plusieurs
informations en même temps mais est ce
qu'on peut vraiment être efficace
et peut-on s'entraîner pour s'améliorer
on va faire un jeu ensemble c'est le
test de ses troupes il va vous faire
ressentir l'effet stroupe qui a été
démontré par un mec qui s'appelle john
ridley stroup c'est bien foutu
en 1935 dans la revue journal of
experimental psychologique vous devez
absolument faire ça à voix haute ou
alors en chuchotant mais verbaliser bien
chaque étape vous allez passer pour
quelqu'un de chez vous c'est sûr tu
parles à qui brosse troupes
ah oui d'accord et vous devez faire ce
test le plus rapidement possible c'est
très simple pour la première phase vous
allez lire le plus rapidement possible
les mots qu'il y a écrit dans ce tableau
vous lisez les mots tels que tels qu'ils
sont écrits alesi je vous laisse
quelques secondes pour le faire deuxième
phase vous allez dire maintenant le plus
rapidement possible toujours les
couleurs de chaque cadre donc le plus
vite possible allez-y vous laisse
quelques secondes pour le faire
également
[Musique]
et enfin maintenant vous allez me dire
de quelle couleur sont écrits les mots
donc pas les mots en eux mêmes mais de
quelle couleur ils sont écrits et vous
devez faire ça aussi le plus rapidement
possible allez-y je vous laisse encore
quelques secondes pour le faire vous
avez vu allez pas si simple la dernière
phase plus c'est compliqué pour vous
plus ça signifie que vous avez une très
bonne lecture automatique par votre
cerveau les faits se trouve par exemple
est très faible voire nul chez les
enfants qui viennent juste d'apprendre à
dire la difficulté de la troisième phase
il ya eu d'interférence entre à
traitement cognitif sur un autre ce qui
est intéressant c'est donc avant même de
faire deux choses en même temps notre
cerveau semblent parasitée par les
tâches qu'on lui a automatisé combien
programme et je vous mets dans la
description un lien vers les planches de
ses troupes
si jamais vous voulez les enregistrer
dans votre téléphone par exemple pour le
faire sur quelqu'un avec le résumé des
états frédéric paulhan à un philosophe
français publié un article en 1887 sur
la simultanéité des actes psychique
alors il a fait plein de recherche pour
ça ils expérimentent et plein de trucs
par exemple il écrivait du racing tout
en récitant du victor hugo il a fait
plein de tests comme ça et à la fin il
ya isolé deux choses très intéressantes
premièrement la résolution de chacune
des deux tâches et plus long qu'à la
normale et il y a plus d' erreur qu'à la
normale
la deuxième chose c'est que la durée
totale de l'exécution des deux tâches en
simultané est très inférieur à la somme
des durées de chaque tâche qui aurait
été fait de manière isolée depuis de
nombreux travaux ont été faits de
nombreuses études ont été réalisées mais
à notre époque clairement tout va plus
vite le temps c'est un peu devenu
données précieuses savez comme dans le
film time out on s'éparpille assez vide
on ne conçoit pas de faire qu'une seule
chose en même temps c'est même plus dans
nos codes en fait de faire d'être mono
tâche
j'ai un exemple très concret et
j'aimerais bien que vous soyez vraiment
sincère qu'est-ce que vous là maintenant
tout de suite vous êtes en train de
faire en plus de regarder cette vidéo
alors oui je me doute que certains sont
aux toilettes
si c'est le cas un simple double attaque
pas silencieux et pour cause fera bien
la faire dans les commentaires je veux
pas les détails mais les autres vous
êtes en train de faire quelque chose
peut-être en train de regarder la télé
ou d'écouter quelqu'un parlait
en tout cas ce que je sais que c'est que
la majorité d'entre vous sont en train
de cumuler deux actions en même temps on
commence à répondre à la question donc
oui on peut faire plusieurs choses en
même temps mais en détériore la qualité
de ces deux actions puisqu'à chaque fois
il ya un conflit cognitif alors l'idée
que j'ai eu c'est ce que vous annoncer
au début de la vidéo c'est de voir si je
pouvais profiter de ce conflit cognitif
pour mentaliser une personne comme vous
pouvez voir je suis dans les loges du
tas de sénas où je fais mon spectacle
aujourd'hui donc je vais aller
mentaliser le régisseur du théâtre donc
du côté un petit peu l'univers youtube
et ça c'est parfait j'ai besoin que tu
choisisses un youtube heure où on
annonce chaîne de youtube heures ça peut
être plus simple c'est ça un nom de
chaînes de youtube heures dans ta tête
et je peux pas connaître ça tu me dis
quand après ce bon vieil homme c'est le
régisseur de mon spectacle ce soir à
sénas l'idée est la suivante c'est que
je vais te faire faire une action et en
même temps je vais poser des questions
sur youtube heures sauf que tu veux à
pouvoir me dire la vérité ou me mentir à
chaque fois tu vois à chaque coup tu
peux changer mentir ou dire la vérité
mais en même temps tu vas faire un
calcul qui fut la main le tas date de
naissance c'est le 26 mains de 26 mars
82 mille naissances et en tout 80 2 et
ton département de naissance 84 84 et 10
mois un chiffre entre deux élèves cette
fois c'est ok qui va résoudre cette
multiplication tout en me parlant
ne t'inquiète pas ce que fait des
erreurs je vois deux regarde quand on
fait deux tâches en même temps justement
on a vu qu'on faisait souvent des
erreurs et donc il n'ya pas de souci
j'ai envie de déguster quelque chose
pour cette vidéo donc vas-y tu commences
à faire ton calcul et je te pose est
donc des questions sur le youtube heures
et achètent pas tu peux me mentir on me
dira la vérité combiné 1 c'est pas si
simple
c'est un homme tout à fait
et sur youtube il fait du gaming
pas du tout je peux mentir
tu peux des martyrs dire la vérité tout
ce que tu veux et sinon il n'y fait lee
fait des idéaux de beauté je vais pas
mentir durant la vérité je fais toujours
ce que tu fais pas de vidéo de beauté
d'accord c'est bien d'essayer de
l'embrouillé en temps il fait de la
vulgarisation scientifique pas du tout
passé continuent à calculer c'est
important c'est important
c'est quelqu'un de très connu sur
youtube où ces deux c'est à dire qu'à
passer le million d'abonnés d'après toi
ou je pense et fait une vidéo tous les
jours
quasiment couet voire même des fois
plusieurs par jour
plusieurs par jour de 1000 par jour même
chez sir des fous à l'heure il est
d'aller jusque là tu vois qu'il s'est
compliqué tous appelés jeux que vous
venir soit les valeurs de tout en
parlant et en prenant la décision de
mentir au palais et est ce que est ce
que c'est une
une vieille chaîne entre guillemets
quoique à plus de trois ans oui ok et et
c'est quelqu'un que tu aimerais
rencontrer ouais c'est une chaîne aussi
qu'un peu viral sur facebook et tout ça
ou alors on a préféré bouclent chacun
leurs qui mérite parce que je suis une
vérif vérifie en même temps que les deux
actions en même temps maintenant savoir
cacher je dirais par déduction par
rapport à tout ce que tu m'as dit tout
ce que j'ai cherché quel état je pense
que c'est la chaîne 2 ont causé ta
absolument ça c'est ça et ça c'est la
vérité
oui je remercie guillaume donc qui est
le régisseur ce soir tu n'étais pas
comprise de quoi que ce soit mais grâce
à toi on a pu symboliser ce que je vous
parle depuis le début de la vidéo et on
va continuer maintenant avec les
conseils pour aller un peu plus d'un
sens à savoir qu'est ce qui se passe
quand on fait du multitâche vous avez pu
voir et je pense que vous avez eu les
mêmes pistes que moi à quel point
c'était compliqué pour lui de mentir
tout en réalisant ce calcul est ce
conflit cognitif m'a permis de voir mais
très clairement quand est-ce qu'ils
mentaient je pense que vous aussi vous
avez vu ça vous pouvez maintenant avec
cette donnée-là essayer de revoir la
vidéo mais tant que vous savez qui
pensez à vous ont causé et pour la
petite histoire j'ai commencé cette
vidéo d'abord le mental is an même si je
voulais me que maintenant en tout cas ça
m'a permis d'affiner ma recherche en
ayant ces infos là sur le mensonge et ça
me permettait d'aller de manière plus
safe est plus simple que d'autres
méthodes vers la déduction finale
puisque après j'ai appliqué un effet
tunnel du stuff training et puis mes
autres popote de mentalist dont on a
déjà parlé sur cette chaîne c'était la
vidéo pour le prénom d'ailleurs foulard
mais ici maintenant les conseils pour
pouvoir ce petit musée en faisant du
multitâche alors déjà il faut savoir
qu'il ya une étude qui a été publiée
dans n'auront en 2015
je vous mets libyen dans la description
sur la gestion multitâche de notre
cerveau et qui tend à démontrer que
contrairement à ce qu'on croyait que les
ressources cognitives d'un cerveau ne
sont pas partagés quand on est en
multitâches mais qu'elle ne s'altère pas
non plus la réalité serait un mi chemin
entre les deux et les chercheurs sont
encore aujourd'hui en 2007 en train
d'étudier ce phénomène j'ai remarqué ça
c'est juste un avis personnel
d'expérience le camp les deux tâches
qu'on ne réalise
dans son similaire c'est plus facile de
le faire vous pouvez par exemple en
discutant avec quelqu'un vous concentrer
sur une discussion qui à côté c'est à
dire écouter l'autre discussions écouter
ce qu'elle verse un body et lui répondre
si votre discussion avoue personnel
n'est pas trop gourmand en
intellectuellement vous devriez être
capable de suivre les deux en même temps
je vous conseille d'essayer ça dans un
premier temps mais le meilleur des
conseils et je ne savais pas que cette
vidéo allait aboutir à celui ci après
toutes les études que j'ai lue après
tout la recherche que j'ai fait c'est
qu'il vaut mieux gérer les choses les
unes après les autres
il part 8 mai par contre en alternance
souvent cédé à faire un petit peu d'une
tâche un petit peu du nôtre un petit peu
du nôtre revenir sur celle ci sur celle
ci sur celle ci le mieux c'est encore de
créer des to do list et de s'organiser
efficacement
abonnez-vous à la chaîne et like et la
cie la vidéo vous a plu pas silencieux
je compte sur vous c'était ridicule
il ya un bonus en regardant la vidéo
plus attentivement vous allez trouver
une énigme à résoudre à l'intérieur
cette énigme vous donnera de la vence
pour quelque chose concernant un trophée
si vous avez vu cette vidéo par exemple
ça devrait vous parlez à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]